i think um
i think people struggle to make sense of
dangerous things at the moment i mean
you you mentioned 911 that's a very good
example of this because
in a different era an attack like that
might have been understood
in a political way um as
you know a specific threat a threat that
needed to be dealt with
from a group of people who needed to be
dealt with it would have been viewed
primarily in that fashion but what
happened with 911
in the current era when it happened is
that it unleashed
or intensified all the backward
reactionary
deranged trends that had already been
gathering pace i mean the
very clear example of that is conspiracy
theories
which very swiftly took over from
rational discussion in some
quarters and we were suddenly led to
believe that
george bush did this not al qaeda israel
was probably involved in all these other
theories that floated around
in the absence of a framework through
which to make sense of these kinds of
events
and the absence of a framework at work
or the absence of a shared
common outlook or a common language is
often the
um i i think is the starting point of
the derangement
of the current moment and particularly
in the aftermath of something like 911
and of course
there was also a lot of the politics of
fear
there was a panic there was
authoritarianism there were very
various illiberal laws not only in the
us but in the united kingdom too
in terms of spying on people restricting
what you're allowed to say
um and so on and so forth so it's very
i find it very interesting the way in
which world events or problematic events
or
threats to our societies
the thing we seem to struggle with is is
finding a common way to understand them
and talk about them and instead
it fractures very quickly and you have
these competing claims as to
what is the real origin of this event
what is the real meaning of it what's
the real impact of it
i think with covid what i find quite
striking about
the covid situation is that i think
um it was less the threat from covert
that
intensified the derangement and more the
lockdown because what the
lockdown we had a lot down in the united
kingdom it was supposed to be for three
weeks it ended up being
closer to four months um of course there
were lockdowns in europe there were
various forms of locking down in
different american states
and what the lockdown did it
intensified the atomization of people
it complete in the united kingdom
context it completely broke
up the public there was no longer any
existing public instead we were all
scared individuals
at home whose only duty was to wait for
the daily government announcement on how
bad this disease was
how many people had died and we were
just all watching the death tolls and
listening to the horror stories
no connection with others no democratic
sphere
parliament was suspended the right to
protest was
outlawed there was no way in which
people could come together to discuss
things or talk about things and i think
in that moment
when the broker when the public was
completely broken up and any sense of
collectivity was completely undermined
we saw the intensification of
um particularly that very atomized
individuated culture of identity
of um a sense of victimhood
of people people just conceiving of
themselves as a broken down
identity one identity group versus
another identity group
those were the things that intensified
most during the lockdown period and i
think it's fascinating
that the lockdown only really ended in
the uk anyway
with the black lives matter protests
which was really
an explosion of identitarian politics an
explosion of what i would consider to be
regressive
politics a very destructive illiberal
censorious moment statues were torn down
statues were defaced
comedy shows were banned um people were
forced to take the knee and if they
didn't they were humiliated in public
ritually humiliated for days on end so
it was striking to me that lockdown only
came to an end with this incredibly
physical manifestation of the
identitarian
uh regressive politics and i think that
really demonstrated to me anyway
that the thing that intensified during
the lockdown moment was
primarily the the cult of identity which
i think is going to get worse and worse
so uh if i understand you correctly
you're saying
that the atomization of uh
our collective sense being broken apart
physically from each other
resulted in an obsessive focus on
identity because the things that tend to
blur that line
are connections to other people whose
identity may be related but isn't
the same so i see a lot in that
on the other hand there's certainly
something to be said
for the fact that people have over time
innovated new modes and
you know as much as zoom
is lacking for example in
some of the face-to-face sense people
have defaulted to it and so i see
simultaneously people uh being atomized
and also people coming together in ways
that they were reluctant to
before not maybe that because there's no
meaning of physical proximity anymore
due to the fact that we are you know
even if we're down the street from
somebody we may still
do a conference call with them that that
may
um it may allow us to choose too much
who it is that we're interacting with so
that we may or at least some of us may
default into
finding people whose identity is very
similar and therefore creating
um identitarian echo chambers
yeah i think that's very true and um
it's like you know social media and
these other technological breakthroughs
are a double-edged sword in a way
in the sense that they allow us to
communicate in ways that
our ancestors could only have dreamt of
i mean you know it makes the it makes
the printing revolution of the 15 and
1600s look like a
minor affair the fact that pretty much
anyone on earth who has a mobile phone
can publish his or her views
instantaneously with no need for an
editor
no need for a priest no need for a
politician to tell them what they may or
may not say
although social media the social media
oligarchs are now taking over that role
increasingly and are now saying
there are certain things you can't say
publicly but
that's an incredibly radical moment the
internet revolution was an incredibly
radical moment unprecedented in human
history and that's
all to the good but what's happened i
think with technology in particular
is that it has molded itself around
cultural trends that were pre-existing
and so i'm always reluctant to engage in
technological determinism i don't think
technology
makes us the way we are in some
instances
in some historical moments that may well
be the case but i think
most of the time technology we kind of
get the technology we deserve as a
society
so you know in earlier periods the
technology was
you know ships that were capable of
traversing entire oceans
because that moment was one of
exploration and daring and
the expansion of human knowledge or the
technology might
be splitting the atom and nuclear power
or the space race and various other
things which tended to reflect
a sense of aspiration a sense of
ambition a sense of desire
amongst sections of humanity what we
increasingly have today is
technology that's that allows us to live
in our bubbles which which allows us to
to navel gaze um to self-reflect
to express our identitarian
impulses in a public way um
and to as you say create echo chambers
and reinforce
our existing views and protect ourselves
in many ways
from ever being confronted with opposing
views technology is now very good
at protecting the individual from
exposure to
contrasting viewpoints contrasting
political ideas and so on
so the great irony i think in modern
technology particularly
online is that it creates the lonely
crowd phenomenon we're all
you know there was a lot of talk about
the internet reconstituting the public
and possibly even
constituting a global public but we all
engage with it
very much as atomized individuals
expressing our own
identitarian ideas or our own sense of
self
into the void essentially and i think
what technology has done it's it's
shaped itself around the kind of
regressive trends that had been taking
hold for
the past few decades and i think one of
the striking things about the covid
period is there was
a lot of connection people did try to
make connections
during the lockdown in the uk for
example there were lots of local groups
who were
doing shopping for people and looking
after the elderly
there was one where i live and i was
involved in that and people
really did want to have a sense of
taking some collective responsibility
for their
fellow citizens but the speed with which
that got
pushed aside by all the old rubbish
i thought was so striking so very
quickly the
the pandemic was racialized for example
we were told
it has a disproportionate impact on
black people and
south asian people um which may be true
for various reasons but it was the
intensity of the racialization and the
way it was
folded into the victim narrative i
thought was very striking
um of course we've seen the rise of
censorship there are now certain things
you're not allowed to say about covid on
youtube or on twitter and
other platforms um and
and as i say the explosion of uh
identity politics which i think
really reached its crescendo after the
murder of george floyd
so that's what i found depressing about
covert and very interesting about the
moment
we live in there was a collective
impulse there were people saying
we have to pull together but they were
conquered
by the continuing assertion of the
regressive trends of our time and i find
that quite worrying
[Music]